comme avec alaoui président de
l'institut marocain d'intelligence
stratégique et éditorialiste également
pour la tribune afrique bonsoir monsieur
des mecs alaoui merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors le
marocain va prolonger jusqu'au 10 juin
l'état d'urgence sanitaire et le
confinement la situation sanitaire
justifie t'elle cette décision selon
vous le maroc depuis le 13 mars
lorsqu'il a décidé de boucler son espace
aérien plus une semaine plus tard de
prononcer le confinement généralisée à
appliquer sur instruction du roi
mohamed6 le principe de précaution
maximum on est donc dans le prolongement
de ces doctrines du principe de
précaution maximum en estimant que les
infrastructures sanitaires et des
principes de santé ne doivent pas être
mise sous pression et ce au stress on
voit déjà les résultats de cette
politique de confinement strict qui est
appliquée dans l'oreille chérifien
depuis depuis deux mois et quelques
maintenant moins 2 200 morts sept mille
personnes contaminées plus de 95 8 est
certes une économie à l'arrêt mais en
tout cas pour l'instant la santé des
marocains est préservée je pense que
c'est la priorité absolue du chef de
l'état lorsqu'il a décidé que le
principe de précaution maximum serait
appliquée justement vous l'avez évoqué
l'économie a le maroc perd 100 millions
d'euros par jour de confinement c'est
évidemment beaucoup d'argent pas de
concession donc pour l'économiste un peu
l'un vers 102 l'exemple suédois bien
plus au nord c'est un choix parfaitement
assumé en tout cas dans le discours
politique et dans ce discours des
pouvoirs publics c'est un choix qui est
clairement à subissent une situation qui
n'est pas différent de ce que beaucoup
d'autres pays ont entrepris en matière
de mise sous cloche de leurs économies
le temps que la pandémie soit soit soit
maîtrisé dans le cas du maroc de
surcroît il ya une connexion avec
l'économie mondiale avec le sud de
l'europe et des conditions ne sont pas
réunies aujourd'hui pour que l'économie
puisse redémarrer totalement et paiement
mais il ya des indications et la presse
se fait l'écho du fait que certains
secteurs de l'économie devrait
redémarrer avant même que la levée du
confinement ne soit ordonnée par les
autorités compétentes
quels sont justement ces secteurs parce
qu'on sait par exemple que le plus gros
fonds en danger sont notamment les
usines avec des foyers de comptes emails
contamination important alors sur les
usines à hadath quelques foyers qui ont
été relevés et qui ont effectivement
permis une contamination beaucoup plus
rapide parce que c'est un lieu dans
lequel il y a de la proximité dans le
cade il ya des échanges
je sais que une grande partie de
l'industrie est en train de s'organiser
pour pouvoir redémarrer avec des plans
de continuité des plans de continuation
avec des ces gestes c'est comme gestes
barrières qui seront organisés au sein
de toutes les usines vraisemblement ce
seront les entreprises des plus
stratégiques celles qui ont le plus
besoin qui sont le plus au coeur du
tissu productif du pays et qui ont le
plus grand taux d'employabilité qui
seront celles qui sont favorisés par les
pouvoirs publics en matière de
redémarrage on imagine peut-être que la
saison estivale qui approche à grands
pas avec ses nombreux touristes enlevés
au maroc justifie peut-être un
confinement prolongé aujourd'hui vous
comptez certainement ouvrir les portes
que la situation soit peut être assainie
au maroc pour cette saison estivale
pour l'instant il n'y a pas d'indication
claire ni de communiqué de la part de la
branche de l'exécutif sur quand est ce
que les frontières sont ouvertes mais il
faut savoir que nous savent également
dépendants de la réouverture de l'espace
schengen puisqu'une grande partie des
touristes qui convergent vers notamment
les zones estivale du royaume arrive de
cette zone schengen et que pour
l'instant on ne voit pas encore la
réouverture de ces endroits là mais
évidemment le secteur du tourisme est
une grande préoccupation pour le maroc
il ya 10 à 13 millions touristes en
incluant les marocains résidant à
l'étranger qui viennent chaque année au
maroc
mais il ya aussi un autre facteur qui
est important qu'il convient de
souligner à ce stade c'est que chaque
année les marocains lorsqu'ils vont à
l'étranger dépenses plus de 2 milliards
d'euros dans des destinations étrangères
il est vraisemblable une très grande
partie de marocains passent les vacances
de cette année
dans leur pays peut-être que l'occasion
de pouvoir le redécouvrir il ya une
grande communauté marocaine également en
france les marocains qui ont sans doute
très envie de revenir dans leur pays
d'origine cet été est ce qu'il y à
quelque chose qui est prévue sur ce
point qui est envisagée à ce stade je
pense que les autorités sanitaires mais
également à des organes de sécurité et
puis la chefferie du gouvernement
évidemment sous la tutelle du padd du
palais royal n'a pas encore donné
d'indication claire sur quelle serait la
doctrine qui serait appliqué à partir de
cet été
je pense que tout le monde ressent la
frustration de nombreux marocains
résidant à l'étranger qui voudraient
pouvoir revenir auprès de leurs familles
surtout que l'aïd el kébir arrive que ce
sont des moments de retrouvailles qui
sont importants pour les communautés
pour qu'elles puissent se retrouver mais
à ce stade il n'y a pas encore
d'indication claire sur ce que seront
les trois prochains mois on suivra donc
ces développements merci en tout cas
beaucoup d' el malek alaoui d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france